what's up believe nation and welcome to
another YouTube hangout super excited to
be here I am testing out my new
microphone I don't have the filter yet
for it so hopefully I'm not popping too
many peas and bees and teas and all that
but I'm excited to be here with you I've
made a commitment to every Thursday have
a hangout whether it's me by myself
asking questions not asking questions
answering questions or having a guest on
to come on with me so here we are I see
a bunch of people already here in the
live chat if you have a question for me
leave it there tag me makes it a lot
easier for me to see the questions and
let's dive into it we'll see how far we
go half an hour to an hour max and then
moving on to other things
so let's go tag me up what do we got I
saw a question at the start about
cryptocurrency so the kiru is asking in
which cryptocurrencies do you invest in
Evan I don't invest in any
cryptocurrency uh one I don't think it's
great to put money into something that
you don't understand and I see
cryptocurrency as just another
opportunity like there's tons of
opportunities there's there's an
opportunity driving by every single day
and the danger you get into is when you
jump on an opportunity because you think
it's gonna be hot but you don't know
anything about it that's when you lose
your shirt that's when you lose your
money that's when it's not a great idea
so if I was getting to cryptocurrencies
I would really want to try to understand
it I made a video on my channel not that
long ago
earlier this week sharing the advice and
wisdom from successful people and their
views on cryptocurrency so I would
encourage you guys to watch that if
you're thinking about it but I have no
interest I'm no interesting in the
cryptocurrencies it's just not it's not
something that I really care about just
the same as real estate it's the same as
network marketing it's the same as
affiliate deals the same as investing in
gold you know invest in a bunch of stuff
it just doesn't interest me
and so because there's so many
opportunities is driving by every day
and because that doesn't interest me
then I'm not gonna focus on it and I'm
gonna keep working on what I'm doing so
that's my answer in the kiru I love to
from you guys who's going hardcore
cryptocurrencies I think in with
investing in any of these kinds of
things in general you have to be willing
to don't don't be spending money that
you don't have
don't be spending money don't take out a
loan to go invest in the
cryptocurrencies it's not a smart idea
what do we got
oh it's poppin' we've got questions
popping in I see my name Lili Lili MA
from unlocking Lili what's the ideal
present for Evan I'm a I'm a really
tough person to buy a present for
because I don't really value things that
much what did Nina get me this year what
did Nina get me this year it's pretty
bad that I don't remember that right we
lose to get Lily's getting me into
trouble Nina got me something amazing it
was just fantastic but I don't remember
um it'll come to me I hope I don't know
what to get me like do your thing I love
it when people start chasing their
dreams and so the most valuable thing
that you can get me is to take advice
that you're getting from from me my
channel and do something about it that's
that's a great gift more than any any
and then tell me about it so I feel good
that's a great gift more than getting me
a new coffee cup or something
that's a deal present for me Mitchell
does YouTube not count videos towards
your storage limit I have no idea but I
don't think so
I think if you're talking about like
Google Drive storage limits YouTube
videos don't count because they're being
stored on YouTube what else mr. random
what keeps you awake at night
what keeps me awake at night um nothing
really I think it depends on the day to
day there's nothing worth is there's
this recurring thing that every night
I'm I can't go to sleep because I'm
thinking about something often it's when
I'm doing something during the day or
just get inspired and get this great
idea and I need to go work on it or Nina
wakes up has to go to the bathroom that
keeps me awake at night but last night I
slept
amazingly well even though she got up
twice to go to the bathroom so that's
rare usually I wake up when she wakes up
I know that wasn't the question that you
really answered but you know I wanted to
go a little little deeper for you there
but in general now nothing nothing
really keeps me awake at night unless
I'm dealing with a specific problem that
I need to get up and solve and then I'll
get up and I'll solve it because I know
that going to bed will make a difference
I need I need to resolve it good
question what do we got ello ello Legend
yo what are your news resolutions I
don't have any I don't really make news
resolutions you know it's just another
day January 1st is just another day if I
want to change something if I have a
goal then then like start right now
what is it December 28th now you still
have three days before the end of the
year go go do it immediately take some
momentum on it I really suck with making
five-year plans as soon as I want to do
something as soon as in my head I start
working on it and it just starts to
happen I remember wanting to to build a
house it was a goal of mine to build a
house from scratch
and as soon as I started thinking about
it then within a year I had my property
purchased and we destroyed what was
there we excavated and started building
the house that's just the way that I
work as soon as I get something in my
head then I need to start making
progress on it and not wait until
January first to make that happen I
thinking beneficial for some people like
fresh start great but I think every
morning's a fresh start like I wake up
today is a fresh start I can go off and
attack what I want to go and attack and
I don't care if it's January 1st
December 28th Maine 22nd you know it
doesn't matter what else yo.hannes hello
Evan how many hours do how many hours do
you deep work a day deep work is
interesting um I don't know I don't
track these kinds of questions I don't
keep I don't keep track of that to be
honest I don't really delineate a lot
between like work and everything else
that I'm doing because if I'm taking
timo for a walk I'm still probably
thinking about something that's
happening that I need to work on or new
idea
a shower I'm still probably
brainstorming and coming up with how I'm
gonna tackle a new problem in my
business I don't I don't have a set from
this time this time every week I'm gonna
be working so I don't know I don't have
answer that question for you Albert I'm
curious about your point of view on
patience with people work and goals
that's an interesting one I come from I
think opposites eyes on this one so one
I think patience is super important I
think it's really really important to
understand that you're playing a long
game that your goals are likely not
gonna happen overnight if it's something
that's worth doing you may never even
accomplish it but you're making progress
towards it and I think it's really
important to take that daily consent or
deceiving your goals and I think if I'm
looking at managing people and the
people around me I have the same mindset
towards them I think in general I'm
probably more patient than the people
around me in that I can see the long
game and I want them to keep working
hard on something and as long as they're
making progress I will hold your hand
like I would I would
I'd much rather not have to hold your
hand across the street but I will hold
your hands across the street as long as
you're willing and as long as we're
making progress and some issues we're
able to go really fast on because they
get it and some issues take a lot more
deconstructing and breaking down the key
is you want to put people at the edge of
their comfort zone constantly you don't
want them to be going slow because you
are the bottleneck or because you think
they should be going slower you want
them going faster and there's such a
thing as pushing them too fast but you
want to be pushing them at the edge of
their comfort zone constantly to make
progress on achieving their goals and
same thing for yourself so I think I'm
the most patient person in my
environment at the same time I think I'm
also the most impatient person in my
environment that I want things to happen
immediately as well and so I don't know
I live in that world of balancing both
of those constantly you know next goal
for the channel might be 10 million
subscribers I understand that that's a
process and
that that's not gonna happen tomorrow
it's probably not gonna happen 2018 so
there's a long horizon to make that
happen and I want it to happen tomorrow
and I wanted to happen in 2018 and so
the patience the lack of patience drives
me to take immediate action because I'm
frustrated with how slow things are
going and the patience also allows me to
stick with my long-term goals when they
don't happen immediately I don't that
makes sense so I'm both I'm both good
that's my thoughts on patience thank you
for the question what do we got Oh
woeful hand me Wow all right I just told
my parents that I will be dropping up
because I want to pursue my dreams they
are with me right now please everybody
help me push this question what's the
question you just told your parents okay
let me know what your question is please
everybody help push this question it was
no question all right well you had a
chance let's keep going guys if you
tagged me I'm much more able to see it
M'Lynn how do you prioritize your
father-son time as your pursuits focus
on content creation absorption how do
you teach him to absorb less noise and
not be a slave to an on-demand lifestyle
so that's a great question so during the
week I have time every day with my son
on Tuesdays I'll end early and go pick
him up from his school and we spend the
the late afternoons and early evenings
together
I don't really push content on him I
think the great thing that my parents
did for me and for my two sisters was
they allowed us to be ourselves and they
encouraged us to be whatever we want it
to be I think it was because you know my
mom's upbringing was kind of strict and
so she didn't want to do that for her
kids and of the three of us I'm probably
the safest if I look at what my two
sisters are off doing and I try to apply
that same mindset to to my son I think
if you look at your your parent
relationship you either try to do the
same thing as your parents or you or you
try to do the exact opposite there's not
a lot of kind of middle ground there and
so I really liked
how my parents raised me and so as an
example my son Hayden is really into art
got a picture from here he loves drawing
he loves art he loves creating and I'm
not fantastic at art I I'm not a huge a
drawing fan I don't have a lot of
guidance to give him on that but
multiple times per week we'll sit down
and we'll draw something together
because it's what he wants to do so
we'll draw a league of Legends character
or a vampire from a movie or something
we'll just draw that together because
that's what he enjoys and I want to
support him on his endeavors I remember
my parents used to wake me wake up with
me and go to garage sales with me when I
was 12 13 years old so I can sell my
baseball cards and that's how I got a
lot of my negotiating down was
negotiating over baseball cards for five
or ten cents with guys who are three
four times my age and they did that even
though they had no interest in baseball
cards and no real interest in business
or entrepreneurship either just they saw
their son take a keen interest in this
and so they want to support them and so
I think that's the best thing that that
you can do one of my habits every
morning is reading a page from the book
top ten was a success and today I was
reading one of the message from Warren
Buffett which was about give
unconditional love and as that's the
ultimate gift that you can give your
kids understand that they may not and
probably won't want to do what you do in
terms of the same line of business the
same kind of work maybe the same
education they probably don't want to do
the same thing as you do and supporting
them on their path I think is super
important and so I try to take that
approach with Hayden so the any Content
that I'm showing him is more around what
he wants to work on like how to draw
Vladimir the vampire hey he's finding
the videos and we can see them together
we have some rituals like at the end of
a night I'll always remind him that he's
a Carmichael and chemicals can do
anything so that's as he goes to bed say
I'm Hayden Carmichael I can do anything
and just instill in him the confidence
and belief and I think I think a lot of
it is all
so as Moses just being around me seeing
me a lot of the values just become part
of what he's doing so that's my thoughts
what do we got next
Isaiah how many people do I need to
start a junk removal service one
yourself start stop waiting next
Alexander how do you manage your money
slash budget and more importantly how
did you manage it when you had a small
amount great work thank you for your
videos so you know my first company I
was making 300 bucks a month and you
manage it by just staying within your
your realm
I ate beans for lunch every day I had
the same lunch every single day
I had these mixed beans and I would put
olive oil and some herbs and salt on it
and I and I shook it all up and that was
my meal but how is every day I ate that
every single day and so you do you do
what you have with what you have that's
it I hate spending money till I'm making
money and so I made a focus of not
trying to go into debt not trying to
spend a whole bunch of cash that I
didn't have because I think that's a
recipe for bankruptcy and so you just
manage you just manage you know how much
money do you have you understand that
it's always about your effort your
hustle your your hard work your energy
even getting into new things looking at
my youtube channel as an example I had
money but I didn't spend any of it to
launch his channel it was all me I had
money I had a team of people in my other
company and I started it myself I made
every video myself I did the research I
did the editing I did in front of the
camera behind the camera it was all me
to prove that this is something that I
wanted to keep working on and it worked
out and I as I made money with the
channel then I invested into bringing on
the team and that first was just an
editor and then I built and grew up from
there but even even as I launch new
projects I hate the idea of spending
money till I'm making some kind of money
back so that's how I still trying to
manage things
[Music]
ANP life what what are your top three
things you value in life what are the
top three things I value in life
somebody asked me yesterday what my top
three priorities were what are the top
three things I value in life you know
hearing that thinking about values
brings me back to my one word which is
believed and the three things that I
break that down into is one passion so
doing work that you love I try to do
work that I love as soon as I stop
loving something I'm gonna check out so
YouTube videos if I stop loving making
YouTube videos I'm out I'll sell the
channel or just stop and move on to
something else because you can't create
amazing things doing work that you hate
or doing work that's just okay you have
to love it you got to love the work that
you're doing daily so that's one two I
say is impact I need to be doing work
that I feel is having an impact beyond
myself so making these videos having a
commitment to keep doing AMAs or having
people on my channel if if this wasn't
having an impact if if five people
showed up to this and I say Evan you
suck we hate these Amy's great you know
I'll stop go do something else you know
the work that I do has to have an impact
and I try to encourage others as well to
make their work meaningful in that it
fills your own soul but also contributes
to the world somehow and three just
self-confidence having the confidence to
go after the things that that I think
are possible and that you say are
possible go after your goals and not
just sit on them forever so those would
be my three what else Tom for someone
who had nothing what steps can we take
to build an online business you don't
need anything to build an online
business you just need your your energy
your hustle your heart it's figuring out
where you can bring value that's the key
what are you gonna do online there's so
many businesses that you can do online I
have an online business this is I have
multiple online businesses it combines
what I'm great at and I love doing with
where I can provide value to people and
so that's really what you have to figure
out what's the value that you're going
to bring people and then from there you
can reverse-engineer the business model
there's so many ways to make money
online and none of them require upfront
cost
you can start any business online
without having a ton of cash it's just
figuring out where you can bring value
focus on where you can help people and
bring value that's where you're gonna
win Dani how do you deal with
distractions how do I deal with
distractions so I start one by trying to
live a no crisis no distraction business
just as a general rule so as an example
I have a phone but I haven't had a phone
number for over a decade
why because having a phone number is a
distraction there's no phone in my
office if you can't call me it's not
possible there's no number goes right to
a voicemail because it's other people's
agenda for your time in same thing
around checking email and checking
social media you know I checked social
media once a day when I'm biking and
doing my workout in the morning and if I
skip my workout I skip my social media
email I'll check when I'm outside when
I'm standing in line when it's there's
no specific time where I'm doing email
everyday and that allows me a lot of
blocks of focused work and I used to
pride myself as the guy who would answer
email quickly email came in I got the
little Outlook notification the little
bell goes off like aw I'm gonna respond
and then somebody would be really
grateful that I responded so quickly
right like I respond and in a minute or
less and then they write back say thank
you so much for responding so quickly
and then that just feeds a cycle that
that means I want to do it again and
again and again I want to keep making
people happy because they're giving me
the little boost but I realized I was
never working on anything important I
just kept working on other people's
projects and responding to other
people's emergencies and I wasn't able
to hit off any of my big goals and so I
decided to switch and it was a slow
process but it's to the point now where
I'm on Facebook it's the fastest way to
reach me and my team and my family are
on Facebook and I have that open during
the day but people don't really bother
me on it because I know that one the
people on there are only my friends and
team like people who actually know and
two that I really value my time
and so step one is just creating an
environment where you don't have a lot
of distractions so you don't have to
handle a lot of distractions because
they're known coming at you I think
that's the easiest easiest way to get
started - then just value in your time
and making sure that if you do get
interrupted with something that you're
willing to say no if if it's not a
priority it doesn't mean you have to
hurt somebody or be mean to somebody
just that you're working on something
more important and if that still doesn't
work I would say
take a take at least one day a week off
and just go somewhere and just shut
yourself off like if you can't have the
discipline to create the schedule for
yourself the routine for yourself go
somewhere I remember when I was writing
my book the first one your one word I
would spend a day a week every Tuesday
and I would walk the whole foods and I
would just work there and I had no
distractions and also just physical
distractions just being in the same
environment and you know having my
fidget spinner with me you know like
there's lots of different kinds of
distractions in being in your regular
environment so forcing yourself to leave
once a week until you can get the
discipline to to bring that to your
regular environment I think can make a
big difference I feel like I'm staying
on the spot I want to move more but this
microphone is right here so anyway
hopefully the sound is coming up pretty
well what do we got Diane best advice
only no phone number eliminate
distractions love this wisdom all right
cool glad you're feeling it Diane I I
had a cell phone for about a month with
a number just around the time my son was
born because just in case you know just
people always say well what about what
happens in emergencies it's like what
are the what are these all-important
emergencies that are happening all the
time when your life that you need to
have a cell phone number for what is
this emergency when was the last time
you had such a major emergency that you
needed to have a cell phone number and
worst case if you actually are an
emergency you can use somebody else's
cell phone or you can connect to
somebody using your phone and data get
on facebook then on hangouts is there's
other ways it's not emergencies it's
other people's agenda for your time it's
their emergencies don't make your
emergency my emergency
I'm gonna decide what's an emergency to
me but when my son was about to be born
I had a cellphone number for a couple
months just in case just in case you
need to get that call and then after he
was born I disconnected it and I don't
have a number anywhere next miss Ora how
can I help you wow that's a great
question
I don't know you know if you look at my
website I've updated it and it's it's a
constant work in progress working on
today to look at the bottom there are
some immediate needs that I'm focused on
in terms of helping my mission if you
fall into any of those categories
that's amazing maybe we can work
together apart from that I would say
being being a force for good whether
it's on my channel leaving comments
encouraging other people responding I
really love it when you guys respond to
each other's comments and our God in
helping each other giving encouragement
much more than just saying hey that was
a great video Evan but if somebody posts
with a question or thought and then you
guys respond and jump on board and help
them I don't think we have enough
supporters in our lives in general and
so I think if you could be that person
for somebody else in believe nation that
would be awesome
Mitchell next the mic is huge
I like the previous mic Evan Carmichael
uh yeah man it's it's huge right my face
I'm actually supposed to supposed to
come in here supposed to talk a little
closer but I don't have the thing on it
yet so hopefully though the quality is
better because I have my blue Yeti which
you guys can never see off screen but
anyway let me know hopefully the sounds
is better if it's not sounding better
than maybe we'll go back next check your
trade do my first YouTube live this
afternoon the topic is an AMA and also
live end of day stock analysis any tips
anything to avoid definitely try my tips
would be don't put so much pressure on
this first name a being awesome expected
to suck expect to be nervous expect to
not have a format to not know what
you're doing
expect maybe nobody to show up or only a
few people expect not to get amazing
questions expect it to suck and just
keep going right and don't don't have to
make it perfect
and then do this one and then do another
one and just see like do you like it
that was it was it fulfilling you know
yes I sucked but can I see some progress
here and did I like doing it they want
to go back and do it again and so that's
what I would say you know and all of the
mechanics don't really matter as you do
it you'll you'll figure out your style
your flow how you wanted how you want to
answer questions and good luck that's
exciting man next Joe Wayne what is the
one quality that you admire the most in
hate the most on a person I like your
jacket by the way happy 2018 you and
your family watch more success uh so for
me believe is what I like the most I
love people who make me believe in
myself more and also try to spread that
to help others who are champions and
supporters that's why I encouraged in
the last question about if you see
somebody who needs help in the comments
like be a supporter I don't think we
have enough of that in in the world and
what I hate the most is a little man
it's the opposite is the little man is
the person it's a reference to my first
book the person who just hates on your
ideas tells you all the reasons why it's
not going to work and why you suck and
why you can't do this and why your goal
is never going to happen that really
drives me nuts so that's what I hate the
most as a characteristic in people what
else Simran how can an organization
progress how can organization progress
there's a lot of potential ways to take
that question I would say though in
general you just need to find the thing
that you love doing that you can
continue to add value and explore in I
think it's the difference as you are
growing a company between just following
best practices and then creating the
next best practices if I look at my
youtube channel as an example at the
beginning I didn't know what I was doing
and I sucked and I was learning the best
I could from other people who had
success I learned from Tim Schmoyer and
Derral Eve's and all these guys who were
talking about how to win on YouTube and
I loved it I ate it all up and I started
applying their techniques and it started
working and then what you'll find is as
you get higher and higher up and better
and better what you do there's fewer and
fewer people who can
eat you so if you've never done a
YouTube video before then anybody who
has done their first YouTube video can
teach you can teach you the mechanics
and give you advice but as you get
better and better
mmm you're not gonna be able to get
advice from as many people and so that's
where you need to have that constant
push in that drive inside yourself to
now make the new best practices so what
I'm doing on YouTube I'm I'm doing
things that other people aren't doing
and I'm trying to make the best
practices and there's still some people
that I listen to and we talk shop and we
we break down ideas and a lot of these
guys are off doing their own version of
breaking the mold and creating new best
practices and so that's just how it
works is you get better and better at
any skill and I would encourage you and
your organization to think about that
what are we going to work and be
dedicated towards that we're gonna learn
all the best practices and then we're
going to create the new best practices
having a dedication to keep going what
else ah Mike just graduated college now
applying for various jobs don't feel
like I know what I want
still I just have safe bets you feel me
yeah men welcome to life you know that's
most people my process is what I would
encourage you to do is figure out your
one word when you understand what you
stand for you know what your most
important core value is then you can
start to build a life around it and
whenever you have uncertainty or on
clarity understanding who you are as
human being makes every path every
decision a lot easier if you don't know
what you stand for you don't know who
you are then you have your living other
people's version of your life your
parents want you to do something your
boss want you to do something your
friends want you to do something and you
get conflicted because it all sounds
good but that's not your reality that's
their reality for you and you will
likely not be happy just being a junior
version of your parents and so you need
to do the work to figure out what it is
that you stand for and then build a life
in a career around that so I think
figuring out your one word is the most
important exercise that you can do in
your life and it gives you guidance the
rest your life so go
it's exciting place to be and in
Congrats and leave me leaning in on the
uncertainty because I think a lot of
people come out of college or come out
on to the next career path super certain
but it's only because somebody else
planted that certainty in them not
because it's coming from an internal
place and so if you really feel the pain
in the struggle of it that's great
because that pain will lead you to solve
the problem figure out your your core
value and build from there William any
advice with someone coming to Toronto
without knowing anyone and wants you to
start a business how does one begin so
congrats welcome to Toronto it's an
awesome place if you're coming now it is
super cold at the moment we're going
through an extreme cold alert so one
bring extra warm clothes to does a great
organization called Enterprise Toronto
that I would look up and they basically
help new people to Toronto and in the
city start businesses so they can walk
you through all the mechanics of what
you need to do from a legal perspective
they also have events and networking
that kind of stuff and three like it
doesn't matter just do your thing
if you can provide value you can win
anywhere they could drop me in the
middle of the Sahara Desert and I'll
figure out a way to provide value and
win right so take that mindset that it
doesn't matter it doesn't matter that
you starting from scratch it doesn't
matter that you don't know anybody you
have no resources you can win if you can
provide value you can win what do we got
Bruce who do you think is the best
financial guru Jay Morrison or Robert
Kiyosaki I don't know who Jay Morrison
is Robert I only know from from real
estate stuff so if you're into real
estate I guess he doesn't work marketing
to you learn from him and Jay I don't
know go look him up I think for me much
more than taking having one guru that
you look up to is taking the bits that
you like from different people so you
may like one thing about me and you may
hate ten other things about me that's
fine like you don't need to I am not the
person you need to become but I may have
one element that you love what I do that
you can learn from and apply that to
your life into your business and that's
always my goal
so I learned something from every video
that I post up if I'm not learning from
it I don't post it there's been lots of
videos that we have cut because I just
didn't learn anything from it and so I
look at everybody that we've ever posted
on the channel as people that are my
mentors that I've learned something
specific from Steve Jobs is a great one
I love his vision what I want to be a
parent like him probably not you know do
I want to take fatherhood advice from
Steve Jobs no right I'll take that from
somewhere else but it doesn't mean he's
a terrible person or human being I could
still learn something from him to help
me be better and so if if you're looking
at these two people as potential mentors
for you then I'd say both learn from
both you get something from Robert you
get something from Jay as long as you're
learning you're improving that's it
that's all that matters stop looking for
just one person to help you learn to
learn from people who've had success
Jason take bits from successful people
gee if only someone put together videos
that highlighted missing successful
people Jason it's not a question don't
tag never sign a question but thank you
for the love and and honestly it's why I
made this channel is because I needed to
be around more successful people and I
wanted to have that as part of my daily
routine regimen to fill my head with
people who are accomplishing big things
and pushed me to want to do more so the
good thing is hey there's three videos a
day that you guys can learn from there's
always something there that you can use
to help you break free from the chains
you're facing right now and take it to
the next step
next lots coming in shake music shake
music please answer how to commit to
multiple goals every week and make
progress YouTube family writing it's so
hard to keep going so Juan don't focus
on the hard what do you want you want an
easy life you want to race
three-year-olds like don't focus on it
being hard of course it's gonna be hard
if you're doing something big and
important and valuable it's gonna be
hard every great thing in life guns on
the opposite side of doing a lot of hard
work and so stop complaining and embrace
the
because the heart is awesome so start
there
second you need to map your calendar to
your ambitions so what's happening in
your calendar in your schedule needs to
reflect your goals if you have a goal to
do something but then it's not in your
calendar it's not in your daily
activities then you're not gonna do it
it's just a dream it's just a hope and
so moving from goal to execution comes
from the activities that you're doing on
a regular basis
so I am constantly updating my calendar
I have a general framework and then I
would say at least once a month I'm
making tweaks to it and maybe he wants a
quarter bigger changes and it's not okay
its quarterly review time I'm gonna go
and sit down and look at my calendar
it's more when I feel something is out
of whack basically I have a goal that I
want to accomplish and I'm not spending
enough time on it and so by spending
more time when it means something else
has to come out and so everything goes
into my calendar personal time time with
my wife time with my son vacation time
everything goes into my calendar and I'm
I have my youtube channel I have I have
my website I have working with Lily I'm
working with Alex working on a bunch of
different businesses I don't even know
everything is in my calendar I just live
by my calendar and so it's it's it's
it's hard but it's awesome it's great I
love it and you should too if everything
in your calendar and this is I guess a
good measure you want everything in your
calendar to be something positive that
you are looking forward to doing I want
to spend time with Alex I want to spend
time with Lily I want to spend time on
my youtube channel I want to spend time
with you guys I want to spend time with
my wife and my son and work you know all
this stuff the more that these are
positive things that you're you're
fighting for attention in then it just
becomes a matter priority
how much time do you want to spend on
your YouTube channel to accomplish your
goals how much time do you want to spend
with your kids how much time you want to
spend with your family because you don't
want to spend all day every day with
your family you're gonna go nuts and you
also you crave purpose you want to do
something meaningful and so just making
sure that your daily activities that are
in your calendar map to your ambitions
and
to your goals and that's a constant
evolution and yes it's going to be hard
and that's awesome next they know nice
they know the moderator growth /
improvement is super important whatever
you're into what is what is one thing
you're trying to improve on at the
moment what is one thing that I'm trying
to improve on at the moment there's a
lot one thing I'm trying to prove on
right now that I'm working on today is
better articulating the message on my
website which is really getting it out
of my head and down on the paper so I
created a new concept called the circle
potential I am trying to solve the
world's biggest problem which is
untapped human potential and I started
breaking down what that looks like and
now I need to add more meat on the bones
so I did a huge piece on self-awareness
if you click on the self-awareness link
you'll see lots of ideas there now I'm
working on environment and so the
environment really important you know
from the physical environment that
you're in to the music you're listening
to to the other resources you're
consuming to the people in your life the
haters and the supporters getting all
that out of my head and into the website
so that it can be communicated when
somebody goes and hit the mic when
somebody goes and checks out the site is
something I'm working on improving right
now what do we got - bass el mention a
successful doctor entrepreneur if there
is any way to combine both have we done
any doctor entrepreneurs I'm assuming
you mean like a medical doctor or not uh
not as someone who has a PhD I don't
know that we've done one so I don't know
I'm sure they exist I'm sure there's
lots of them what I would suggest is go
like so if I haven't done the work then
you do the work right like if you are a
doctor and you want to be an
entrepreneur then go find go find that
person you know
their risk for you guys that you can
consume whenever you want it's beautiful
but I'm not I don't have all I don't
have all the answers I don't have all
the resources and so go find it yourself
and then learn from them if somebody
else has done it you can too and Milan
success is one of the fastest ways to
accomplish your goals next Elzy REO i'm
11 years old trying to start a business
I want to know the fundamentals of
business and I saw your video but I'm
only 11 so I can't get a job so what are
the fundamentals first off I love this
man I so wish I was 11 and I had YouTube
to be other answer to ask questions to
people what was I do when I was 11 I was
I was just starting off in my baseball
card business 1 don't let your age like
let your age work for you instead of
against you don't think because you're
11 you can't do things think of what can
I do because I'm 11 people will give you
more time because you're 11 people will
answer questions for you because you're
11 I love it right that little caveat I
made at the beginning I've answering
this question I wish I was 11 be able to
ask questions to people people will let
you off the hook a lot more will give
you more guidance and wisdom and
mentorship because of your age and so I
try to find ways to use that as a
positive and say I'm 11 this is my time
like this is my time to crush it right
now because when I'm when I'm 20 people
won't give you as much time I got it I
got a leverage this my time is running
out right as opposed to I'm only 11 I
can't do anything I don't know anybody I
don't know anything so one I would use
that to my advantage I would look at
every business this person that you
looked up to and then try to make some
kind of contact with them whether it's
on YouTube or Twitter or Facebook or
Instagram or snapchat I would I would
reach out to everybody individually and
ask them a specific question so the
fundamentals of business I would answer
that as being just provide value the
more value you can give to somebody the
more you're gonna make the more the more
awesome guy you can make provide the
more awesome money you're gonna make
money is an exchange of value and so
that's what you need to be able to
provide now as you make your way along
your journey as you get more specific
questions then you can start asking
people those specific questions and get
answers because you're still young
and you got you got that working for you
so
good luck man I'm super excited to see
how you grow next the road runs
suggestion would you make a top ten on
Liz Murray there was a movie made on her
true story homes to Harvard any requests
this is not the place because I don't
keep track of it and I don't remember go
to any video look at the description
there's a request line go there cast
your vote the more people vote on that
idea then the more bubbles to the top
and those are the ones that we tend to
look at so good luck a cache Evan please
answer how can I increase my business
and marketing knowledge and become a
marketing genius
so make a decision that every single day
you're going to consume marketing
content and then you're going to apply
it so there's one of just being book
smart and that's by going out and
researching and within within a couple
weeks you could know everything about a
certain topic you want to learn Facebook
marketing in a couple weeks you could be
an expert on Facebook marketing from a
book smart perspective you can read all
the case studies you can watch all the
videos you can learn everything there is
to know from a book smart perspective on
Facebook advertising then you need to
start applying it right apply it to your
own business apply it to friends of
yours find somebody who can do something
free for and get some experience doing
it and then adjust so what you know in
theory and then what you actually go out
and apply and do is going to is gonna
change it's not going to work exactly
like you think it's gonna work and
that's fine you've got to put in the
reps you got to practice you got to
practice you got to practice you got to
practice that's it it's deciding that
you're gonna be a marketing expert
learning everything you can about the
industry getting as much experience as
possible helping people and then as you
do it as you're actually providing value
to people then you can start to charge
we did a video not so long ago with Lily
who had unlocking she's got the
unlocking Lily series on my channel of
invested into her business at the start
she wanted to be speaker she now evolved
to also being a coach and she loves
coaching and when she started coaching
she had a lot of knowledge but she
hadn't done a lot of coaching and so she
did a hundred free coaching calls with
people
and she started getting paid after the
50th one but then she still did more
free work afterwards and now she's
building up her roster now she's good
enough that she's providing value that
people are wanting to pay her and
increase in the price of how much they
pay her but you gotta put in the reps
like would you do a hundred free market
assessments for people would you do 100
free campaigns for people would you do
100 free Facebook Ads for people maybe
they're paying the the marketing budget
but your service is free because you
need to get better you need to know what
you're doing but that can all happen
quickly it really just gonna be a
function of how much time you're putting
into making that happen how much time
you're gonna put into learning
everything because again within two
weeks you can figure it all out and then
how much time you're gonna put into
reaching out to doing tests to put in
your own time in this could happen all
in the first six months of 2018 or could
take you five years to do it it's up to
you how long you want to take next
Michele Michele with Annie I like that
worked hard for years for goals several
opportunities here now at once busy life
ahead day job family business how to
make it all work without being fractured
not that pretty similar to the question
answered before you just schedule it in
you have to pick your priorities
especially if you're you're working a
full-time job already you have a limited
amount of time in the evening you want
to think what's the highest leverage
that I have on my time what can I be
great at that will allow me to
eventually make some money from this and
be able to transition away from my
full-time job so that's my immediate
goal it's trying to figure out for those
hours that I have every evening first
make it consistent like every day you
have to work on your business every
single day even if it's half an hour you
need to build momentum momentum is so
important it's really hard to get back
on the train
after you've fallen off just from an
emotional perspective you got to do it
every single day it's a priority it's
important to you then I'd be evaluating
from these from these multiple
opportunities that you have what's the
one you're most excited by what's the
one that can lead to the biggest
opportunity for you to have an impact
and then focus on that and focus on
where you can bring the most value
what's the highest use of your skills
your knowledge your experience so if you
suck at making websites and the
make your website right like start with
a Facebook page figure out what you're
really amazing at and that's where you
want to be spending as much time as
possible next Sharonda please answer at
what point do you quit your full-time
job so this I think is really
personality driven some people need to
quit and go all-in because that's a
personality some people can't do things
in chunks they have a really hard time
doing it and so if that's your
personality if you need to burn the
boats if you need to take a flamethrower
to your boss's office and like there's
no way you're gonna go back if that's
the only way that you make progress then
then now you quit now and you figure out
a way that's not me
for me I would much rather ease my way
into it
I would I would want to prove it to
myself that this thing works and I would
quit my full-time job when I had enough
money from my side hustle to support
myself to not make a ton of money not be
buying Lambos not be off you know
spending money like crazy but to support
myself to to pay the bills pay the
Internet have food on my table and that
would mean taking a step back because if
you're making a nice income from your
job and now you're taking you know maybe
half of that and that's going into your
side hustle as extra income now to go
and cut out the full-time keep hitting
my mic now to go back and cut out the
full-time income and only live off of
the side hustle business that's really
tough and so you're taking a step
backwards but you've bought yourself the
time to be able to go all-in on your
company and so I I would quit when I had
enough money to survive and really you'd
be surprised at what you could survive
on you'd be surprised
you think you can't but if it's really a
priority if it's really important for
you you can so I just keep that in mind
and again just build towards your
personality play mods Evan Carmichael
best morning habits so best I think the
most important thing is figuring out
what's best for you for me what I do I
wake up I tell myself I'm gonna have a
great
I go to the bathroom I read a page in
the book and I find that that helps the
top ten book because I wanted to reset
every day I need inspiration and
guidance every day to live a more bold
day ahead it's easy to coast when you
don't have somebody pushing you so that
helps me then I drink a huge glass of
water more than the glass like this one
liter thing of water and then I'll go
work out do half an hour on the bike
burn off 300 calories answer my social
media questions and then then get to
work come back up and do some while do
some breathing exercises a little cold
shower and then I'm off to work I think
what's most important is figuring out
what works for you I think one of the
best exercises you can do is figure out
when you felt the most bold when you
felt the most alive when you felt the
most unstoppable and then what led to
that so what was the trigger was it
watching the video was it having a
conversation wasn't reading the book was
it listening to a podcast like what's
the thing that gets you feeling bold and
feeling amazing and then find a way to
incorporate that into your morning
routine because I think too many people
wake up like an accident
happened to get inspired on a Thursday
afternoon listening to a podcast or
watching YouTube video and they're on
fire for the rest of the day and then
they wake up the next day and they're
starting over and that sucks and you
don't want to do that and so if you know
what triggers you to feeling bold and
unstoppable again whatever that is like
drinking Starbucks makes you feel bold
unstoppable great start your day with
that every day
right playing a song on the piano or
doing a meditation or hugging your cat
or playing with a fidget spinner or
watching a video whatever that thing is
it gets you feeling unstoppable put that
into your morning routine and that is
gonna be way more important to be able
to reverse engineer yourself much more
than to look at what I do every day or
Steve Jobs or anybody else
those provides point of reference and
things to experiment but nobody else has
the perfect morning routine for you
you've got to figure out what that is
and you already know what a good chunk
of it is just by reverse engineering
what makes you feel bold and unstoppable
next xeno again if someone would want to
do an interview with you what's the best
way to contact you not for me
if you want to do an interview with me
best bet email my assistant Sandra at
Evan Carmichael comm and we can look at
setting that up
you should sound a Thursday I do I've
got interviews today after this skype
calls hangouts Thursday's my public
facing day next day Roachy any thoughts
are we launching a business with
existing customers reasons to relaunch
any thoughts from relaunching the
business with existing customers reasons
to relaunch what are the reasons to
relaunch I don't get the question I'll
take a take on it though you want to
relaunch a business because you love it
if you have taken a break from the
business and now you're coming back to
it
did you really even love the business in
the first place is this something that
you just chasing the opportunity or you
actually have a deep passion for it it's
really I'm really skeptical of somebody
who's relaunching a business because if
you were willing to walk away from it
the first time why come back to it it's
hard usually it's because of you just
see an opportunity if you let if you let
excuses or life get in the way before
what's to prevent that from happening
again and so I would just make sure that
whatever you're doing whether it's
relaunching a business or starting new
that that you love it like this is gonna
be a priority for you that it's not just
chasing the money but like what you're
doing is meaningful important work and
you're gonna continue to hustle hard on
it every single day it's a heart it's a
heart check it it's a gut check much
more than that I think this can make me
some money check there you go Emanuel
what are the keys to to manage your team
remotely after you hire the right people
well that that's a big after after you
hire the right people is where most
people make a huge mistake
they don't have the right people but
assuming you do have the right person
you're one of those you 5% who hire
properly I would say just making sure
that you that you care about the people
like these are people they're not just
order takers I think it's really easy as
an entrepreneur to lose
the fact that you have people on your
team and that they're human beings and
that it's great to be able to delegate
tasks away like oh great I don't have to
do this crap that I hate anymore I'm
gonna go give it to that person and now
I can focus on bigger things and your
mission and your vision and that is an
awesome feeling but know that those
people are still people and they have
their own mission and they have their
own goals and their dreams and
understanding what it is that they want
to do and how you can be a part of that
really makes it important for you as you
grow your business your role in the
company decreases as a percentage of
what's being created right if you have
one if you're the only person you're
making everything for the company if
you've got ten people making stuff for
the company you might be the single most
important person as a founder but your
output compared to what everybody else
is doing is less like maybe you're only
contributing 15% of the output and so
the other 85 is coming from your team
and so if you have people who are not
happy who are not in the zone who are
not feeling fulfilled then everything
suffers and so your job as you continue
to build the business is to make sure
that the people feel fulfilled and are
happy and so whatever that looks like
I do regular check-ins with everybody on
my team we have we have meetings to talk
about what's happening with projects
we're working on but I'll also have
one-on-ones just keep hitting it my
video editor Christina warned me that I
would hit my mic a lot if it was here
from the bottom but I'm still hitting it
when it's here so we'll see anyway I
have I have quarterly meetings as well
to talk about just life how things are
going how they're feeling can I help
what's going on are you happy you
fulfilled any ideas you want to work on
so it's not just that the task based
work of did you get this done how about
this brainstorming ideas for what to do
but more caring about them even at TDS
it's not a remote business but I still
meet with everybody on the team
assistants and instructors so that would
be around 10 people I meet with Alex
once a once a week and I meet with
everybody else once a quarter sit down
and just talk about life and where
they're going and how tedious might play
a role in their growth or me personally
even if it's totally outside
of the business and so I think it's just
letting people know that you care about
them it's it's it's having their their
heart and soul and not just our minds
that becomes really important with a
virtual team but not just virtual any
team it's the same thing you're managing
people play mods why most billionaires
is so serious I don't know I don't know
I don't know if I would agree with that
but who cares I don't understand who
cares don't worry about them worry about
yourself next Brittney are there other
ways to market a business other than
using Facebook absolutely just research
ways to market your business there's
tons and look up to your heroes Facebook
is a tiny way to mark your business
there's other social media channels
there's Network gain there's PR there's
SEO there's going to conferences
conventions trade booths
there's knocking on doors picking up the
phone referrals partnerships tons of
different ways to grow your business
next what do we got what do we got if
you tagged me it's easier to see how are
you Evan NIR I'm great
how are you I love this my foots falling
asleep because I'm in the same spot so
I'm bouncing a little bit but otherwise
I am great Youssef have you ever been
lazy yeah I think everybody's been lazy
I don't think that I don't think there's
such a thing as a lazy person I think
people just don't have goals that
inspire them in an environment that
pushes them to do better it's easy to
get lazy even when you've had success I
thought there's a lot of entrepreneurs
who have a lot of success who are lazy
they worked really hard and then they
hit their goals and then they started
coasting and they got lazy there's a guy
I was talking to last week who's built
the insanely successful business but is
getting bored of it and it's just it's
his time to move on
but he has he says sees a dollar signs
he's the opportunity but he's not into
it anymore and so he's he's slacking
he's coasting he's lazy's hokhmah going
on vacation and just finding himself and
doing a bunch of you know
other activities instead of pouring
himself into meaningful work and
that's what happens when you're doing
work that you don't love or you don't
see a purpose in then you're gonna get
lazy and so the solution is do work that
you care about that is meaningful to you
create an environment and a morning
routine that supports you and builds you
up and then attack that every single day
and then kind of pay attention to
yourself because I see it as windows of
opportunity you know you might have a
six month window or five year window or
somewhere in-between where this is the
thing that you love this is this is what
you want to do but you might get tired
of that too don't assume that what you
love doing right now is gonna be the
same thing in 30 years or in two years
or in three months and so it's having
that sensitivity to yourself to know
when your interest is falling off when
you are no longer passionate about
something and then you're only doing
this because one you just see this big
opportunity to because of a commitment
to somebody else
three because of you know other people's
expectations of you those are not the
reasons to do it you do it because you
love it and as soon as you stop loving
it
you want to pay attention to that and
jump to somewhere else next Joanne I
really love your channel thank you for
doing this not a question but thank you
Joe and I appreciate the love next Mike
from your experience is selling your own
unique brand apparel online profitable
this is a business I'm researching for
myself every business can be profitable
every business is tons of profitable
apparel companies and there's tons of
payroll companies who go bust every
business can be profitable it's not the
industry that matters it's your love for
it it's the product it's the experience
you're creating so get into it for the
right reasons Johnny 9 how many books do
you read a month not a lot how many
books you read a month depends on the
book and if I read it all the way
through but not a lot I don't know one
two not a lot mostly because I don't
consume content the best through books I
like learning through video how many
videos were consumed a month holy cow a
lot
lot 1 because it's part of this is I
made a business around it right take
something that you love and turn it into
a business that can provide value for
other people so my Tuesdays are full up
on watching videos and reproving the
content for you guys to create my next
week slate of content and then as other
channels that I subscribe to and I learn
from and I watch no no specific time but
when I have spare time I think it's
really important to develop a habit of
learning and growing so that you're not
just static and staying where you are
some people that's podcast from people
that's book some people that's videos I
listen to zero podcast I've never
listened to a whole podcast all the way
through I don't think it's just hearing
audio is the worse for me and so it much
rather watch a video and sometimes read
a book what else what else what else
what else
Paul I'm trying to consume as much
material and Adam how making money do
you recommend any books on the subject
Paul it's easy making money's about
providing value period stop chasing
money start finding what you love doing
that can provide value that's it don't
waste your time on the other books I
just gave you the I just give you the
key that's it
now go figure out what you love doing
and how you can provide provide value
around that and you're in business but
Jeremy Jeremy Wow just having this on
while I work and it's and it's charging
alright that's interesting I don't like
having audio on while I'm working I have
a productive playlist called ant vibes
which I love which I've had on all day
today but it's instrumental the science
at least says that you work better with
instrumental music on behind you
something with a beat but no lyrics even
it's a song that you know because the
lyrics will distract you where the beats
helped you actually work harder so I
could not work with me talking in the
background but luckily I don't have that
problem I don't have to listen to myself
and work at the same time time for one
more question then we'll move on I got
to wrap up how much hit hit his eeeh how
time you sleep
I guess it asked me how much time do I
sleep a typical day I start winding down
around 10:00 I'm probably in bed by 11
and I'm usually up by 7 so that
theoretically would be 8 hours but Nina
is up a lot during the night and so that
wakes me up I don't always have restful
sleep but again you know it's the wrong
question ask because much more important
than how many hours you sleep is what
you're doing with the hours that you're
awake I I could put I would I would put
my 10 hours of work or 8 hours of work
or 4 hours of work against up with my 4
hours of work against somebody's typical
workday and I would bet that I crushed
them 99% of the time just in terms of
output of what I'm creating in 4 hours
compared to somebody's 8 hours and so
you don't need to wake up an hour
earlier and cut yourself off of sleep to
have success you just need to really
audit you have 24 hours in the day so
even if 8 of them are sleeping you've
got 16 hours in the day don't tell me
that those 16 are optimizing you're
hustling really hard and working your
face off because you're not and so the
answer is not I need to go down to five
hours of sleep the answer is let me look
at my 16 or 17 that I'm actually awake
doing work and make that better make
that more productive and that's not just
work work it's also family time it's
also looking after your health my goal
is not to be working 24 hours a day it's
that in whatever I'm doing I'm present
and I'm fully enjoying it so when I'm
with my wife and with my wife I'm not
being distracted by other things when
I'm talking to you guys I'm talking to
you guys I'm not I'm not thinking about
my wife and other things right where
most people you're working on something
you get distracted you're thinking about
something now something more you're
gonna go what you're gonna do next like
being the moment get your work done and
that doesn't have to come at the
expensive of sleep so that's what I got
thank you guys to the love it's been an
hour it's crazy time flies so quick when
I'm chatting with you guys I'm gonna try
to keep this commitment I'm enjoying it
so far hopefully you are to having a
regular Thursday session either with me
or with a guest and I hope you guys have
a close to the year that's awesome I'm
heading to Dallas tomorrow night to
celebrate New Year's for any of you guys
who are in Dallas there's a video that
actually just probably went up on my
channel to meet up we're doing a
Saturday morning I meet up at Cafe
Brazil in Dallas for any any locals
there and I hope you have an amazing
close to 2017 awesome start to 2018 and
I will see you guys all soon I believe
in you I hope we continue to believe in
yourself and whatever your one where it
is much love guys I'll see you soon